[Musik]
bin ich jetzt singen könnte würde ich
jetzt natürlich rechtlich singen aber
ich kann es nicht also was ich herzlich
willkommen zur sallys welt heute feiern
wir geburtstag denn die kitchenaid wird
100 jahre alt 1919 wurde die
küchenmaschine als haushaltsgerät in den
usa auf den markt gebracht dann wurde
auch der name kittel gegründet und ich
habe mir gedacht komm wir machen eine
geburtstagstorte
hier steht sie ich habe eine
geburtstagstorte gebacken und werde sie
heute auf der ambiente in frankfurt auf
der messe an den kitsch made stand
bringen und dort übergeben
die kitchenaid ist komplett essbar ihnen
habe ich nur ein kleines gestell aus
holz gemacht damit ich einfach die
stabilität habe diese besteht aus einer
reis crispy masse und ist überzogen mit
garage und von dort und hier unten weil
eben himbeereis meine lieblings kitchen
etwa aber ist und die ist die ich mir
eben zuallererst gekauft habe habe ich
eine himbeere torte gemacht im innern
mit einer himberg bucht einlage einer
richtig leckeren hinweg rehm und mandel
böden superlecker super saftig und so
erst einmal zeige ich euch jetzt wie die
kitchenaid und die grundstruktur
hergestellt wird
ich mache das hier gerade die
holzkonstruktion für die kitchenaid und
bereit ist jetzt vor für meinen mailing
für alex alex sich bereit ist für dich
für der holzmeister ja ich glaub du
schaffst es aber alleine oder ok er
versucht es dann alleine sorgen zu
machen also hier ist der arm hier ist
der fußball coach nate und das
zwischenstück und es wird jetzt alles
ausgesetzt und darf mich jetzt hier in
fichten tannen holz genommen mit zwei
zentimetern stärke und das wird jetzt
einfach mit der stichsäge ausgeschnitten
[Musik]
jetzt nur noch schön schleifen und dann
kann man uns zusammensetzen
[Musik]
habe ich jetzt die platte dann der fuß
und hier der keeper die kitchenaid
immerhin und dran
damit schauen kann und jetzt muss ich
diesen fuß hier am unteren ende
befestigen
das bei euch jetzt kurz vor und dann
kommt einfach zu schrauben rein und dann
könnt ihr hier einfach montage kleben
oder heißkleber draufmachen den fuß
ansetzen
so hat er schon mal richtig guten halt
und dann einfach auf der rückseite die
zwei schrauben rein drücken
mainburg da müsst ihr euch halten starke
mann zur seite holen
da hatte alex in der tat sehr groß
stabil
darauf kann ich dann den kuchen
anrichten jetzt kommt der arm drauf und
dafür einfach eine wasserwaage nehmen
hinten an die kitchenaid setzen und da
sieht man auch da ist ungefähr ein
finger breit platz
also hier auch jetzt die wasserwaage
hinsetzen das obere teil draufsetzen und
fest verschrauben
[Musik]
hab ich jetzt also mein gestell für die
kitchenaid und jetzt könnt ihr entweder
kuchenbacken zb den saftigen
schokoladenkuchen von meinem blog oder
ihr macht das ganze mittels christinas
ich mache jetzt reiß crosby zum einen
weil man es wirklich supergut formen
kann
kuchen kann man auch super zu schnitzen
und zurechtschneiden allerdings möchten
wir wahrscheinlich die kids schnitt auf
der messe ein bisschen ausstellen und
damit der kuchen nicht schlecht wird
mache ich weiß crosby denn dies auch
nach ein paar tagen noch genießbar und
wirklich super lecker für die reis
crispy maße nehmen die einfach schoko
christie's das ist dieses müsli wassers
manchmal zum frühstück gibt und es gibt
hier die marshmallows beides eins zu
eins gemischt mit butter gar nichts als
die marshmallows schmelzen und das geht
am besten in der mikrowelle
da kommt jetzt die butter rein da musst
du echt aufpassen die masse ist echt
richtig heiß jetzt einfach schön
vermischen
draußen wird übrigens grad die
außenanlage noch gemacht daher die
ganzen bau geräuschen unter murat
bastelt mir sogar eine schöne
abdeckhaube glaube ich hat er zumindest
versprochen
bin mal gespannt bezeichnet es gleich
die hände und die hände können wir
einfach immer städten
dann klebt nicht so sehr
[Musik]
diese rasse ich muss mich nicht
beherrschen dass ich die nicht so
komplett auf esse also echt lecker
schmeckt und jetzt könnte so einfach
hier entlang fest drücken und die
kitchenaid so gut es geht nach vorn und
ich habe jetzt erst mal nur einen
kleinen teil reis frisbee gemacht denn
die kühe ja auch wieder ab und dann kann
ich immer wieder marshmallows schmelzen
wieder verkneten und einfach so die
formschön vollenden
und natürlich darf die schnecke
entstehen
[Musik]
die grundform gefällt mir so schon mal
ziemlich gut
ich habe zu überall so ein bisschen mehr
masse aufgetragen später kann ich
nämlich nach dem abkühlen und fest
werden einfach das ganze so ein bisschen
zu schneiden und dann wird auch die
oberfläche gleich ein bisschen glatt das
könnte jetzt ab noch ein bisschen warm
sogar wird schon fest hier vorne fehlen
noch der kraft anschluss und dafür habe
ich einfach die marshmallow masse hier
den ausstecher eingedrückt mit dem
richtigen durchmesser und da kann ich
später hier vorne dran setzen
aber das mache ich erst separat wenn
hiervon das schon drauf ist sonst wird
einfach ein bisschen zu schwierig so
jetzt einfach ein bisschen aushärten
lassen und ich kann mich ganz kurz
ausruht denn es war ziemlich anstrengend
während die kitchenaid noch aushärten
ich habe schon lange schlüssel darunter
gestellt kann ich ja schon mal die
garage vorbereiten denn ich werde später
diese kitchenaid mit der garage
streichen damit sie später den von hand
darüber legen kann darf habe ich jetzt
hier sahne aufkochen lassen macht ihn
heraus schwarze herren schokolade ein
jetzt einfach kurz einrühren und bei
raumtemperatur abkühlen lassen bis sie
schön streiks fähig ist
[Musik]
jetzt eine halbe stunde später ist die
maße schön fest geworden wie so ein
müsli und jetzt kann ich mit einem
messer ganz vorsichtig hier entlang
schneiden und der kitchen reformen geben
[Musik]
jetzt bestreite ich die torte ganz grob
mit der garage stellen sie dann kühl und
nach der kernzeit david teague anna
schon ein bisschen fett und dann kann
ich so schön glatt abziehen
[Musik]
während die jets im kühlschrank noch
fest werden kann kann ich schon mal die
kuren tage vorbereiten ich möchte eine
platte machen und dieser große kuchen
diese platte die kann man eben auch
angeschnitten gegessen werden und ganz
zum schluss können sie dann auf dem
messestand die kitchenaid anschneiden da
habe ich mir gedacht was passt am besten
zu kitsch made in himbeereis einen
mantel kuchen mit einer hierbei frucht
füllung und einer leckeren vanillecreme
ich mache jetzt erst einmal die böden
die kann ich heute backen und morgen
werde ich dann den kuchen füllen heute
bereit ich dann auch nicht funkt einlage
vor und dann passt alles zeitlich
perfekt ich zeige euch mal die zutaten
für den wandel rührteig verwende ich
sechs eier eine prise salz etwas vanille
extrakt 300 gramm zucker jeweils 300
gramm sonnenblumenöl und buttermilch 450
gramm mehl ein päckchen backpulver 200
gramm gemahlene mandeln und etwas
zitronenschale abrieb ich habe jetzt
hier ein vielleicht bereits vorbereitet
und den bug rahmen auf 30 x 30 cm größe
eingestellt und das ganze mache ich dann
viermal also insgesamt backe kuchen und
dann wird die platte schön groß zuerst
kommen jetzt die eier mit dem salz
zucker und vanille extrakt in die
rührschüssel und die eier zucker masse
wird dann für etwa 10 bis 15 minuten
lang richtig cremig verrührt dann kommen
die zwei flüssigkeit mit dazu und dann
nur bei niedriger stufe kurs einrühren
zum schluss können die jetzt noch das
mehl backpulver und den mandeln mission
und die zutaten ganz vorsichtig
unterheben
gemeinsam mit dem abriss der
zitronenschale
[Musik]
jetzt kommt der teig in die vorbereitete
backform und das ganze mache ich wie
gesagt vier mal und es können immer dann
in der zwischenzeit machen wenn die
kitchenaid im kühlschrank ist was die
schocker kitsch made und gerade etwas
abkühlt
[Musik]
jetzt mache ich dir geben bei frucht
einlage dafür habe ich jetzt 1,5 kilo
abgenommen
die sind jetzt gefroren und dann nehme
ich dann noch etwas wasser und als
geliermittel nämlich keine gelatine
sondern agrar- und da könnt ihr bei der
menge einfach immer auf der rückseite
schauen da steht dann nämlich ein
päckchen unter 500 gramm
ich war jetzt drei päckchen also 45
gramm und da gibt es einfach
unterschiede zwischen magazine dann geht
es doch ein vegetarisches stelle im
mittel also bei mir passen jetzt 45
gramm und ihr schaut einfach bei euch
auf der rückseite okay denn da gibt es
unterschiede
ein bisschen zucker gebe ich dazu damit
die frucht einlage nicht zu sauer ist
und dann wird das ganze aufgekocht und
muss mindestens zwei minuten lang
sprudelnd kochen und dann kann ich denn
entsprechende formen und öl
[Musik]
bei den formen nämlich jetzt hier
einfach zwei rechteckige formen ich habe
jetzt mehr auflaufformen wichtig ist
dass man sie mit frischhaltefolie
auslegt und wichtig ist natürlich auch
dass die frucht ein lager mit der form
in eurer gefrierfach passt der die
frucht anlage kommt dann morgen gefroren
in die torte
[Musik]
am besten bekommt ihr diese rundungen
immer glatt mit seinem kleinen
kunststoffteil habe ich einfach ein
joghurtbecher genommen und die
seitenteile ausgeschnitten
habt ihr in groß und klein und dann
nehmt ihr eure finger gab da zum einen
die wärme und zum anderen könnte auch
noch tasten wo die ganzen beutel sind
und dann einfach schön glatt streichen
so finde ich sehr schön so kommt sie den
kühlschrank und ich kann schon mal die
deko vorbereiten für die decke teile
nehme ich jetzt blüten passte weil
blüten passt einfach schön aushärtet und
festwirt ich habe die jetzt bereits
schwarz gefärbt mit etwas lebensmittel
passte
jetzt mache ich hier vorne diese
abdeckung dann natürlich auch noch die
schraube und im prinzip alle anderen
abdeckungen für diese abdeckung nämlich
die blüten passte und rollsitz 3 mm
stark aus
[Musik]
dann stellte ich jetzt einen kleinen
kreis aus der genauso groß ist und kann
dann mit so kleinen buchstaben hier die
schrift eindrücken und für hier unten
für den fuß nehme ich einfach einen
größeren ausstecher kann den ring
ausstechen und einfach trocknen lassen
[Musik]
ich hab ich ja diese schraube die baue
ich jetzt auch nach und zwar mache ich
jetzt hier einmal dem schwarzen teil
dafür nehme ich ein stück blüten passte
die blüten pastor rollig oval und
schneidet sie unten gerade weg wie so
ein kleiner fingerhut und da nehme ich
einfach zwei pinsel und drücke rechts
und links die seiten ein sodass hier
diese einkerbungen entstehen für die
schraube habe ich hier dieses spitze
stück und jetzt kann ich alles
zusammenfügen mit s-bahn kleber also
hier etwas kleber drauf und damit alles
ein bisschen besser hält ein zahnstocher
rein und dann alle drei teile
zusammenfügen
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich ja bereits alles richtig
gut vorbereitet heute geht es weiter ich
werde heute die torte füllen die kitsch
nicht fertig dekoriert und morgen dann
zur geburtstagsfeier bringen ich mache
jetzt nämlich eine swissmedic
buttercreme und dies ähnlich zur
italienischen buttercreme nur finde ich
einfach die zubereitung einfacher bei
der italienischen macht man in zucker
sirup muster die temperatur messen und
dann zum einrühren
hier macht man es einfach so dass es
erhitzt wird und die buttercreme könnt
ihr wirklich ganz abwandeln so wie ihr
möchtet ihr könnt eine schoko creme
machen fruchtig limonade ich also mit
zitrone oder auch ganz andere
geschmacksrichtungen und das grundrezept
gibt schon auf einem kanal
ich habe jetzt hier folgende zutaten ich
habe jetzt hier weiß zucker salz
himbeeren nämlich denn ich mache eine
hinweggehen
ich habe ich die butter vanille extrakt
und puderzucker und fangt ihr mal
vergessen sollte sich die butter am
vortag raus zu legen dann könnt ihr das
so machen ich habe ziehe nämlich die
portal einfach fein gerieben und hier
aufs blech gelegt und dann bei 25 bis 30
grad im ofen geben dann ist die butter
nämlich schon in fünf bereit und schön
zimmer war das erste was jetzt machen
solltet ist wasser aufsetzen
das wasser muss kochen und dann kann ich
das eiweiß erhitzen damit einfach auch
alle keime abgetötet werden und die
eismasse schön stabil wird also habe ich
jetzt hier weiß da gebe ich dann zucker
dazu es sieht nach ziemlich viel aus es
wird aber auch eine große creme und ich
mache die creme auch zweimal denn eine
masse wäre auf einmal zu viel ist es
halt auch eine riesige torte salz dazu
und jetzt ist im prinzip ganz wichtig
dass die eier zucker masse einfach auf
dem wasserbad für zehn minuten etwa
geschlagen wird das wasserbad sollte
kochen dann wird auch auf etwa 70 grad
erhitzt und dann kann da wirklich sicher
sein
da sind keine keime mehr drin und in der
zwischenzeit werde ich schon mal die
himbeeren mit ein bisschen wasser
einkochen lassen und kann dann später
auch noch die butter mit dem puderzucker
hier in der schüssel verrühren und
vanille extrakt kommt bei mir gleich
noch mit rein
ich weiß es ist ein bisschen viel aber
man muss halt ein bisschen parallel
abarbeiten
[Musik]
jetzt sind alle drei komponenten bereit
die butter ist cremig gerührt mit dem
puderzucker die eiweiß massa ist schön
heruntergekühlt und dieser schritt ist
eigentlich am wichtigsten denn wenn die
eismasse noch zu warm ist schmilzt die
butter und euro buttercreme wird dann
einfach nichts das heißt die eiweiße
richtig schön kalt rühren und dann mit
der butter vermengen und hier habe ich
jetzt noch die himbeeren die himbeeren
die werde ich jetzt noch kurz durch ein
sieb streichen
so kann ich nämlich die kerne entfernen
und die habe ich jetzt einfach so lange
einkochen lassen bis wirklich keine
flüssigkeit oder fast keine flüssigkeit
mehr enthalten ist die muss ich gleich
noch ganz kurz abkühlen bevor ich sie
dann mitunter die creme rühren sie
können das euch auch gerne ein bisschen
einfacher machen und zum beispiel eine
feine himbeermarmelade einrühren
aber ich bin ja immer dabei und mache
das immer gerne alles ganz frisch also
nehme ich meist einfach gefroren werden
jetzt gucken wir mal auf alles in die
schüssel reinpasst jetzt einfach die
butter bei niedriger stufe höher und
langsam hier die eismasse dazugeben
andersrum geht's auch ich habe jetzt nur
die schüssel gewählt weil die etwas
größer ist als die so auch ich glaube
ich mache ich verschmutze die kitchenaid
nicht so sehr
mach das jetzt so und dann immer wieder
anteil dazu und dann gerne einfach ein
paar esslöffel von dahin bei krems vom
himbeer pury ich kann zaubern aus dem
hinweg püree wird gleich eine
hinweggehen
[Musik]
den rest hebe ich jetzt so unter und die
cremes oder nur ganz leicht nach
himbeeren schmecken denn ich habe noch
die hin bei frucht einlage und hier
hilft kann ich die torte bereits füllen
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt hier meine vier
tortenböden die habe ich jetzt über
nacht einfach importen rahmen stehen
lassen haben geschirrtuch drüber
gepackten ganz sauberes und dann lege
ich gern noch nach dem abkühlen und
torten retter drauf damit der
tortenboden einfach nicht austrocknet
und jetzt habe ich den torten rahmen
gelöst in back rahmen habe jetzt die
folie abgezogen und jetzt kann ich alles
schön schneiden mit eher trocken säge so
werden die tortenböden schön gleichmäßig
hoch und dann kann ich nämlich auch den
zweiten tortenboden oben auch schön
sorgfältig abschneiden damit die ganze
torte wirklich die gleiche höhe hat weil
es kann ja mal passieren dass der eine
boden ein bisschen höher packt der
andere etwas tiefer aber im großen und
ganzen sind so schon gleich hoch
geworden
[Musik]
ich habe hier meine holzplatte da ich so
ein großer skateboard einfach nicht habe
und holz ist echt ein super natürliches
material einfach ein bisschen abwischen
und fertig hier kann ich jetzt ein
bisschen von der buttercreme drauf
streichen damit der kuchen einfach nicht
verrutscht und ich habe vorher meinen
kühlschrank ausgemessen die platte passt
gut rein da muss ich natürlich gut drauf
achten und hier am rand lasse ich jetzt
ein bisschen was frei rundherum einem
zentimeter
und deswegen habe ich jetzt hier einfach
ein bisschen klebeband angebracht so
sieht später etwas sauberer aus und ich
habe vor allem auch so einen leichten
griff dass ich nicht mit den fingern
immer in die torte kommen so jetzt den
ersten tortenboden nehmen ich nehme
jetzt einfach den deckel drehen um und
nimmt den als boden und ich habe den
kuchen etwas größer gebacken
das heißt die zwei anderen bleche die
werde ich einfach zu schneiden
aber ich habe immer lieber ein bisschen
mehr da als zu wenig dem zweiten boden
den schneide ich jetzt da direkt zu also
einfach ab messen wie viel ich hier noch
brauche
[Musik]
die custody können wir auf welt ok ich
muss leider sagen ich habe ein blech zu
viel gebacken
alles im büro jubels draußen baustelle
alle alle jubeln juden sie hat was für
uns
[Musik]
wisst ihr es riecht hier einfach so
lecker ich freue mich jetzt schon
ich habe schon was auf die torte und
jetzt einfach die komplette torte mit
der creme bestreichen eine dünne schicht
darauf kommt der gleiche frucht einlage
und wer möchte kann jetzt die torte zum
beispiel noch mit amaretto trinken muss
man aber nicht denn der boden der ist
echt so gesagt
[Musik]
und guckt mal immer wenn ich rechteckige
torten bestreichen oder auch runde
nämlich einfach hier außen gern meine
teig karte dann steht nämlich nichts
über und ihr könnt wirklich super sauber
arbeiten auch gerade bei bis betreuen
zum beispiel echter beste trick ich habe
jetzt die frucht einlagen die kommen
jetzt in die torte
ich werde die eine allerdings ein
bisschen zu schneiden die eine platte
kann ich schon reinlegen
und da ist gefroren sind brechen sie
eben auch nicht durch und der vorteil
ist dass die buttercreme auch gleich
schön richtig abkühlt wichtig ist
einfach immer dass die frucht einlagen
ihnen liegen bei so großen torten mache
ich es gerne ziemlich weit innen also
mit etwa 5 cm und damit einfach keine
flüssigkeit austritt die bruch der lage
ist zwar fest wegen dem acker aber
trotzdem gehe ich da immer auf nummer
sicher
[Musik]
und jetzt kommt wieder die buttercreme
mit der komplet glatt drauf gestrichen
und dann kann ich die torte mit den
tortenböden abdecken
[Musik]
jetzt mache ich den rand noch ein
bisschen sauber und stellen sie dann in
den kühlschrank ich guck mal ob ich nur
noch alleine transportiert kriegen sie
es ein bisschen schwer
doch es geht ich mache den ramsauer
stellte kurz kühl und werde in der
zwischenzeit die zweite portion die
buttercreme zubereiten und dann kann ich
sie aber komplett damit einstreichen
[Musik]
also noch mehr mache es nicht sein
dürfen
es hat gerade so gepasst jetzt habe ich
es für zehn minuten erhitzt kennt jetzt
vom wasserwand herunternehmen dass
vanille extrakt kommt jetzt hier noch
mit rein und jetzt ist ganz wichtig dass
es kalt gerührt wird ansonsten fällt
nämlich die butter massa später zusammen
weil sie schmilzt und ich kann jetzt in
der zeit auch schon mal die butter mit
dem puderzucker in der rührschüssel von
der kitchenaid für höhe
die soll nämlich richtig schön luftig
und schaue mich aufgeschlagen werden
[Musik]
weil ich die männer da draußen die
denken bestimmt ayadi steht der ganze
tag in ihrer küche wir baggern
klopfenstein aber hallo drei ketten auf
einmal ist auch nicht gerade einfach
drei kinder
drück ich habe jetzt hier pinkfarbenen
fondant da nehme ich gerne diesen hier
ich habe ihn aber noch ein bisschen
pinker gemacht denn die himbeereis das
ist ja kein pink sondern eher so ein
knalliges dunkleres pink daher noch ein
bisschen lebensmittel verpasste dazu
gegeben und er von dort ist sehr gut und
auch sehr geschmeidig weil shea butter
enthalten ist um kein parkett und daher
ist auch äußerst elastisch und herricht
aleker ich habe vorher meine hände mit
kokos wird eingerieben
jetzt halte ich den aparten ich kann
nicht mehr und vor allem möchte ich
jetzt erst einmal den oberen teil
überziehen und rollen jetzt dafür auf
etwas becker stecker aus und den rest
den haag ich ein kind brauche ich dann
gleich
[Musik]
jetzt einfach immer schön mit den händen
glattstreichen und dann die reste
wegschneiden ganz vorsichtig
[Musik]
dann mit zwei voll und klettern schön
die oberfläche glitten und die ränder
noch mal richtig schön sauber
wegschneiden
[Musik]
und auf diese art und weise über ziehe
ich jetzt auch den rest der torte hier
vorne werde ich dann so machen dass ich
hier vorne denn von dort ansetzen und
dann hinten einfach verschließen
für schwierig aber geschafft
[Musik]
der teil der kommt jetzt hier unten an
die kitchenaid und da ist es sowieso
holz auf holz das heißt da kann ich
jetzt auch einfach ein bisschen
sekundenkleber nehmen oder heißkleber
damit einfach wirklich ganz schnell
haftet also da kommt man jetzt glaube
ich mit ersten baum kleber nicht so
weiter
[Musik]
jetzt kommt vorne noch der kraft
anschluss dafür habe ich ja bereits
dieses stück vorbereitet und ich habe
mir jetzt gedacht ich mach die
abdeckplatte doch nicht selber sondern
leise einfach ausklammern kitsch made
und dann denke ich dass hier vorne
einfach rein
denn ich habe das problem ich habe gar
nicht so kleine präge buchstaben und ich
habe schon das original trennwand daran
gemacht also kann ich auch die original
abdeckplatte nehmen damit es hier aber
reinkommt muss ich das einmal ausstechen
und dafür nehme ich jetzt einfach einen
apfel ausstecher der ist nämlich genau
so groß dann kann ich es auch gut
befestigen
[Musik]
jetzt gehen mit vom band verkleiden
ich bin den lernfähigen damit so ein
bisschen bakteriums trade in die hand
und werde jetzt die tat streicheln und
zwar hat es den grund dass ich möchte
dass sie ein bisschen glänzt und ich
möchte auch diese übrige becker starke
hier einfach runter nehmen damit das
matte weg geht und die kitchenaid wie
die originale schön glänzt
[Musik]
ein bisschen glanz wird natürlich weg
gehen wenn die fans back trends gray so
ein bisschen eingezogen wird aber
zumindest habe ich jetzt schon mal die
bäcker stärke weg und kann jetzt hier
noch die einzelteile ein bisschen mit
silber metallic farben lebensmittelfarbe
bemalen
[Musik]
ein magnetfeld jetzt auch der bolzen ich
mache keinen bolzen sondern nehmen jetzt
einfach zwei große zucker streusel dafür
nehme ich jetzt hier in bonn tun und man
den meterstab nochmal chemie die höhe
kann ein kleines loch einträgen und dann
diesen zucker streusel einfach ein
kleben
[Musik]
so jetzt noch die kleine schraube fest
machen einfach mit etwas kleber dass
barak leber und alle teile die schwarz
habe die bemale ich dann immer noch mit
schwarzer farbe damit die auch wirklich
richtig schön glänzen
[Musik]
kitchenaid zur seite jetzt hole ich die
torte die ja zum verzehr gedacht ist und
diebe streiche ich jetzt mit weißer
ganache damit sie einfach eine schöne
stabile festigkeit bekommt und das
dauert jetzt auch ein paar minuten
[Musik]
für den rand nehme ich jetzt etwas
schoko und vanille von dann jeweils zwei
päckchen
ich habe jetzt schon weiß geknetet und
zu einem langen strang geformt jetzt
kommt noch marmoriert technik dafür
einfach so ein bisschen zwirbeln sie ist
so schön aus ich würde am liebsten ein
ich mache holz ich mache holz dann so
ein bisschen zieht und das ganze so ein
bisschen formt hat meine schöne
holzmaserung
[Musik]
und dann vier lange strenge zu schneiden
jeweils zwei und dann aus dem anderen
wand auch 2
[Musik]
die lasse ich jetzt kurz antrocknen und
klebt sie dann an den rand der torte
[Musik]
so werde hier ist die echte
sie ist bisschen größer geworden aber
das haus aufhalte es war die erste
maschine
ich muss natürlich hier dran
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zu sein ließen lag
schule ich habe jetzt hier in die mitte
in kreuz gezeichnet hier habe ich die
schablone gemacht von der kitchenaid die
kommt ihr hier später in die mitte lege
ich mal zur seite und wir fangen jetzt
an aus der mitte heraus die fließen
zulegen
und ich habe jetzt hier einfach 5 x 5 cm
große flache quadrate geschnitten weiß
und dieses helle mint türkin ist ich
weiß nicht so ganz
und die habe ich bereits gestern
vorbereitet und wissen antrocknen lassen
und ich nehme jetzt als fliesenkleber
etwas erwärmt und starrte ganache auf
der torte super schnell aushärtet mache
ich das jetzt in etappen und immer schön
eine fuge dazwischen lassen da ich eine
sehr da ich eine langjährige erfahrung
im fliesen legen habe verzichte ich
jetzt auf das fließen calls drogen kommt
[Musik]
das sind ja handgemachte platten wir
raten daher muss man bisher mit sorgfalt
verlegen
jede platte ist individuell bei wer
platten ist das immer so
daher mit äußerster sorgfalt verlegen
wie man machen wasser gucken
[Musik]
jetzt ein bisschen holzleim an den
seiten
hier kommen nämlich die holzteile dran
[Musik]
abmessen abschneiden dran kleben
für die fugen nämlich jetzt einfach
weiße zucker shift die habe ich schön
durchgeknetet und habe ich halt den
vorteil dass sie in der truppe ist und
ich kann so sehr präzise hier drauf
machen
alternativ kann man einfach ein foto
zuckerguss mache mit eiweiß den erwärmen
damit eben die keime abgetötet werden
dann entweder in einen spritzbeutel mit
noch zu erfüllen oder in eine kleine
spritze und dann die vor einspritzen
[Musik]
freitag geht es zur ambiente und jetzt
bereite ich noch die torte fort die
schablone von gestern kamera abhanden
daher eine neue und jetzt lege ich hier
die schablone drauf und ich werde ja
später die torte vor ort dann hier drauf
setzen
und weil die torte ja einiges wiegt muss
ich sie natürlich von unten her
stabilisieren das ist wie so eine
zweistöckige torte ich habe es hier
einfach so dübel zurechtgeschnitten aus
einem rundholz vom baumarkt natürlich
abgewaschen und die kommen jetzt hier
drunter und später kann die torte drauf
stehen ohne dass die untere torte
zusammen sind am besten kurz markieren
[Musik]
doch oder und vor ort nämlich einer
schüssel eine echte schüssel hier habe
ich jetzt nicht nach modelliert die doch
einfach drunter und dann kommen da noch
geburtstagskerzen drauf und dann bin ich
mal gespannt darauf ob die schnellste
also los geht es besser aber die torte
transporte ich jetzt nicht so sondern
die kitchenaid separat die torte separat
die torte muss gekühlt werden und die
kids schnell die steht einfach bei
raumtemperaturen
[Musik]
ein cooler kuchen braucht auch eine
coole box der alex
[Musik]
hier ist immer auf der geburtstagsparty
kitschig wird 100 jahre alt
hätte ich diese maschine zu hause gehabt
hätte ich nicht viermal den teig rühren
müssen hätte alles hier reingepasst aber
weiß natürlich keine funktionierenden
geschrieben bevor ich habe jetzt hier
die torte gleich präsentieren
eigentlich erstmal die neuheiten hier
auf dem stand kommt mal mit
das highlight hierbei kitchenaid auf der
messe ist die queen of hearts re warum
die so heißt weil sich hier an der bande
wurde ganz viele kleine süße herzen hat
und dass wirklich die ganze serie durch
also es gibt nix los da spart mit dem
handrührgerät und das besondere ist
nicht nur das es herzlichen sind hier
auf der banderole sondern es ist auch
ein ganz ganz eigenes droht also nicht
im bett nicht gibt es abgeholt sondern
ganz eigenes grüne fazit
und dann gibt es noch zwei fahrrädern
und zwar päppelt fahren das ist eine
richtig schöne matte oberfläche so ein
bisschen maskuliner kitchenaid versucht
ja auch immer noch ein bisschen was
maskuline riss auch den markt zu bringen
damit eben auch männer mehr und mehr
angesprochen werden und die oberfläche
die kennt ihr auch schon von regus
reisenden maschine
und dann gibt es noch die blue velvet
das ist eine richtig schöne seitige
oberfläche eine weitere neuheit ist der
k 4 100 ländern
der sieg bringt sie zum wissen aus wie
der powerbox blender hat er mehrere
funktionen und zwar hat man einmal
diesen standfuß und im lieferumfang gibt
es an diesen glasbehälter
und dann kann man zusätzlich weitere
zubehörteile kaufen wie zum beispiel den
smoothie to go oder die kreutherin
gewürzmühle die steckt man dann auch
einfach hier drauf und da kann man
kräuter gewürze müsse
foto zucker und alles mögliche zu
bereiten dann gibt es noch den aufsatz
als im stoff
und dann zum beispiel noch die zitrus
presse das prinzip ist ganz cool weil
man wegen hochleistungs mitte hat und
anhebung noch den zusatz dass man zum
beispiel die zypressen nutzen kann
die gewürzmühle oder zum beispiel auch
das motto besser
[Musik]
[Applaus]
jetzt gehen wir die taten so hoch
[Musik]
der bus der busse
nehmt mich gar nicht mit
ich bin jetzt extra zum bus gewarnt
jetzt lässt sich einfach alleine
dastehen
ich habe es hier hoch zu hoch
[Musik]
alle kerzen stecken jetzt kommt die
abdeckung drüber dann fahren wir zum
standort überraschen mal alle von disney
[Musik]
ich guck mal hier
es hat es geschafft in die halle gibt's
noch ein gutes messer zum torte
anschneiden
da gehen wir zum keimen
ich brauche ein gutes messer zum torte
anschneiden ich kriege ja auch wieder
zurück timo kein problem
ich weiß doch wo ich hin muss wir
brauchen was scharfes perfekt vielen
dafür gehören
[Musik]
ich packe noch meine freunde vom bv ein
nämlich auch noch mit
schnecke oder rudolf da ist ein fakt den
router auch mit ein
wir gucken mal wo er ist
oder bist du mit uns geburtstag feiert
meine guten freunde mit
aber freunde mitgebracht
[Musik]
ganz gerade
das
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ok 31
ja
[Musik]
waffen vor
nach diesem tag gibt es wieder eine
scheckübergabe für die aktion pink
dieses mal kann auch eine richtig
richtig großes zustande
95.000 für die akquise und pink die sich
einzelne frauen mit großbrief für die
prävention für die heilung für die
therapie
für mich zukommt
aber ich weiß es nicht
ja
das ausland um die kriegt
rose hingekriegt des jahres 2008 sehen
[Musik]
die lakers trifft
und jetzt einmal gestärkt zur messe
gehen und bis dann durch die messe lauf
nummer schauen was es uns noch alles
neues gibt
zum essen gibt es auch schon
jetzt immer in halle 8 hier geht es mehr
ums wohnen und hier ist bestimmt auch
die almut die kennt er ja und zwar habe
ich bei allen meinen platten beständig
suche hilft machen
[Musik]
lakis richtig da ist wir
armut ist auch da
da gibt es ja sehr gut
ich zeige euch mal war es perfekt hier
schon aufgeschlagen
und zwar habe ich mich dabei almut
inspirieren lassen und habe ich hier
mein badezimmer im prinzip ausgesucht
deine platten eine wandfarbe und dann
haben wir auch die freistehende
badewanne
bei den abgeguckt voll schön geworden
ich guck mir ein bisschen aber ich darf
mich zu akku denn sonst will ich alle
räume so die eigentlich fertig ist
nachher
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das habe ich jetzt ein feuer tisch
entdeckt von happy koling und zwar hat
man da ein richtig schönes offenes feuer
auf der terrasse das ganze funktioniert
mit einer gasflasche und die gasflasche
weil es so flach ist muss außerhalb
gelagert werden habe ich dann nicht so
eine hässliche gasflasche nebendran
stehen sondern ihr habt einfach ein
richtig cool stylischen tisch daneben so
wie hier vorne
da habt ihr wirklich ganz gemütlich
einfach eine offene feuerstelle auf der
terrasse gemütlich aus
dann hat noch einen beistelltisch die
gasmassen versteckt wird
ziemlich cool
[Musik]
ich finde bücher so krass die gucken
sich einfach so ganz direkt an und ich
finde sie ist einfach so die komplette
geschichte in seinen augen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die war echt finde das rechte obst und
gemüse
da kann jeder an so geriebenen knoblauch
freimachen
knobloch saft
[Musik]
es ist echt ein echtes opfer
das ist so cool
habe ich noch nie gesehen also erst eine
sitzbank für eine coole gartenparty zum
essen und dann achtung
egal
apa
genial
zum glück habe ich noch keine terrassen
und gartenmöbel
ach so sauber trick nummer eins kokos
pokus fidibus jetzt wird aus diesen
regalen tisch
oh mein gott
die kohle ist das bitter jetzt habe dann
schön natürlich für eure gartenparty
oder einfach nur ums essen und dann so
können das auch so stehen lassen
oder einfach ganz platz sprach und als
regal
nein das ist genial letztes jahr war ja
japan das partnerland der ambiente
dieses jahr ist das bad in seen und das
passt auch ganz gut denn ich bin ja
schnell hollywood
[Musik]
ich spiele etwas war
wir hoffen
kann jemanden gut aufstellen
[Musik]
sally bott
hier gibt's direkt über teil
vielleicht finde ich das gleich in der
halle und zwar kann man sich das einfach
in den garten stellen und dann kommt
auch den seiten rein
wie es genau funktioniert weiß ich nicht
aber ich kann mal gucken ob ich finde
ich bin jetzt hier und wir wollen zu
halle 12 denn da haben es entdeckt da
gehen wir ein haus mit storage und
aufbewahrung
[Musik]
wow
oder uns zum nächsten halle
ja
[Musik]
doch kopf haben der mutter nach hause
darf
hallo
ich bin einfach die nase nach
er hat dem team fürs team auch gern
danke jetzt hat ja lieb ist teil mit
meinem themen danke
[Musik]
ach so ich erst ihr popcorn und du
schaust dir hier vom ja und ich bin hier
wahrscheinlich meisterkoch deswegen
gerade in frankreich wahrscheinlich das
müsste man die sprache muss mal
probieren und zwar in englisch
das muss man probieren da ist die haben
das enden wo ist ja und auf der enten
bruch und dann ist da einem
kartoffelpüree oder kartoffelpüree ist
aber mit wasabi unterlegt nicht mit
kritik
ich habe schon eine küche die machen das
auch krasse kombinationen
das ist richtig probleme hier man also
ich probiere es einfach auch mal wenn
ich habe schon probiert aber jetzt bin
kamera kann keiner sagen hör auf das
super lecker
jetzt haben wir uns den mann ca
bis man irgendwann traut
wenn einfach weg ich werde einfach weg
so als tue so als weiter moderieren
einfach die popbranche okay so das bag
ich komme jetzt blöd oder so etwas
machen dann unterhalte ich mit ihrer
französisch ok ich unterhalte mich mit
der und sagt wie toll
karamellisierte ananas
wo ist das lecker
es musste probieren ich will ja keine
fremden männer das ist daher gut
[Musik]
jetzt immer risiken sehr wahrscheinlich
denn jede mama und jede oma hatte diese
sahne sprühflasche apathisch im prinzip
schnee von gestern
sahne aufsprühen und sahne steif machen
können sie immer noch aber ist die
flaschen können echt noch viel mehr
jetzt bin ich hier beim zusätze und
josef macht jetzt gleich ein paar
getränke giuseppe hat ihr café und zwar
kalten kaffee ich kenne keinen kaffee
weil ich meinen kaffee grundsätzlich
immer vergessen um stehen lasse das
schmeckt aber furchtbar vater neuer
trend geht ja zur kultur und kultur
heißt einfach der kaffee wird kalt
aufgeblühte und dann mit und versetzt
und dann hast du diesen effekt kennen
und der vorteil der ist es schmeckt da
wo wir und hast du auch im normalen kann
aufgebrühten kaffee ich habe einen dort
zum testen
das ist jetzt gewaltig auch noch mal
kalt man sieht schon ein unterschied
zwischen so sieht so aus schmeckt halt
so leicht bitte schön
und da ist kein zucker drin man hat das
schwer
das schmeckt nicht mal bitte ich möchte
nicht mehr es ist der gleiche kategorie
der schmeckt bitter
mit nie drauf
schmeckt eher cremig und süßlich ohne
zucker das ist echt cool das ist das ist
so wirklichkeiten gab ja auch trinken
das ist unser alkoholfreier cocktail auf
basis von zitrone und user im café
cocktail im prinzip ist es jetzt und
selbstgemachte energy drink murat das
ist für dich eine gesündere energy drink
giuseppe zone spaß
rausbringt gehst du durch die digicam
fall gut ab mich sehr gefreut so weg von
den getränken rüber zum rheiner beim
rheiner gibt es herzhaftes und süßes das
gericht ist lecker und zwar haben wir es
richtig creme und was ist das
lecker darf ich mal bitte ok also da
machen wir zuerst mal herzhaft vom
baldigen comeback rehm
es macht etwas wenn murat
ich habe noch nicht so viel gefühl dabei
das lerne ich noch
sehr gut ist dass kameras super gut
vorbereiten
ganz einfach im kühlschrank stellen und
dann wenn ihre gäste habt einfach kurz
hier verzieren guck mal wie schnell das
geht mit dem drive holt das musst du
jetzt aufhörst aufessen okay ist
zudem kann man mehr und dann noch die
märkte
das noch genug da
u
dann wären sie besuche ich ja immer
gerne freunde
deswegen gehen wir uns zugriff
mit kuchen
ich habe ihn verteidigt bis hierher
unterwegs war nicht einfach
[Musik]
jetzt immer hierbei griff kuchen habe
ich schon mitgebracht es gibt es gleich
zum feierabend die maschine musste ich
nicht mehr vorstellen ihr kennt meinen
alles schneider schon da hab ich euch
schon ein richtig cooles video gemacht
und er hat das meditiert gerate frucht
leder hoch trainer das ist püriertes
gemüse kann natürlich auch mit rein
damit es geht dort in der automaten
denen die sich noch vorstellen
hab ich nämlich auch schon einiges
gehört wie hast du es einfach gerollt
und geschnitten das ist einfach immer
gering das schnecken guckt mal alles
ganz natürlich einfach nur obst gedauert
mango
hier feierabend die torte wurde
erfolgreich übergeben ich glaube sie hat
auch allen ganz gut geschmeckt und zum
beweis musste ich sie natürlich doch
noch an schneiden die kids schnellinger
stehen damit man auch weiß man steckt
wissen kuchen drinnen
jetzt sitzen wir hier noch von freunden
bei krebs zusammen erst mal kurz raus
und dann geht's nach hause der ganzen
welt wird schon auf der standorte gleich
komplett verzerrt das war die
aufgabenstellung ich glaube sie schaffen
und wir haben die echt coole sachen
entdeckt dieses mal war meine tourleiter
ein bisschen kleiner haben wir hatten
einfach die geburtstagsfeier und focus
ich hoffe euch hat das video gefallen
schreibt gerne in die kommentare was sie
am besten fangen wir sehen uns beim
nächsten mal gehalten die begehen dünner
ist so viele wolken haben blumenstrauß
willkommen auf der messe sind wir haben
gar nichts mehr los
[Musik]
gar nichts mehr los und zwar des wagens
zog wir haben ja nichts deswegen wer
eine frage beantworten wie man eine
frage wie alt wurde kitsch ist der
erzählen fragen wie altmodisch mir das
richtig beantwortet gewinnt ein
abendessen mit volkan wahnsinn so oder
anders sein
oder am wochenende mit murat oder wochen
mit mir im paradies bei mir stimmt wir
sind dann bei uns einfach ok für kids
mit 321 haben
[Musik]